not really no I'm not very optimistic I
think that it's going to be really hard
to you know figure out long-term
political and solution military
solutions for Iraq I think that you know
the stability we've seen lips security
is improved in the past year but based
on very fragile to security has she has
gotten much better in the past year but
it really depends on three elements one
of them is the surge in the American
troops you know the Americans rule has
evolved from the beginning of the
invasion from nation building and
bringing democracy to now acting as a
buffer zone between the Shia's and
Sunnis and while really preventing Iran
from falling apart so I think the
question of what happens if the troops
withdraw or what will happen if the
rules on the ground change will really
answer the question of whether Iraq and
stand on its own feet I think also that
you know we've put Sonja insurgents on
American Payroll they're paid about
three hundred dollars a month and
they've asked to be incorporated into
the Shia security forces and the shares
of so far resisted so you know the Sun
is have made it clear that if they don't
get what they want they're going to
start fighting again and there's really
no telling how long the ceasefire with
the most Outsiders militia is going to
last if the Sony start fighting is he
going to fight back so I think you know
it's very fragile and I think unless
there's some political solutions that
can really make people put set the
loyalties of people and the you know
different political parties to their to
their country rather than to their sex
and ethnicities I think that you know
things could unravel again